[Music]
the dive itself was pretty difficult I
had a beautiful descent everything went
well with the saint but then at the
bottom I took my tag tried to attach it
to the velcro on my leg and for some
reason wouldn't attach so I tried that a
few times to have one world record is
outstanding to now have someone
attempting another world record will
really just set the bar even higher
I was a little consent one point I
didn't know how deep I was I didn't even
know if I was gonna make it to my safety
divers it didn't feel that strong but
gradually I guess I started to come back
and managed to get to the surface
there's the most wonderful thing to pink
it see my son do what he does this